vous lu disiez une autre fois c'est
possible maintenant vous voyez que il
est dans un état qui est difficile
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà euh cette disparition inquiétante
de mélodie mendz Da Silva une
marseillèise de 34 ans qui est
introuvable depuis 2 semaines jour pour
jour après un dernier message à sa sœur
sur snapchat cette mère de famille n'a
plus donné aucun signe de vie alors
qu'aucun élément n'aurait pu justifier
une disparition volontaire la
disparition est jugée extrêmement
inquiétante par les autorités elle est
surtout insoutenable pour ses proches le
mari de mélodie affiche ses avis de
recherche son épouse a disparu depuis le
3 novembre de semaines sans nouvelles de
l'esthéticienne de 34 ans le 3 novembre
dernier Melody aurait quitté son
domicile vers 17h c'est 3 jours plus
tard que son mari se rend au
commissariat une enquête pour
disparition inquiétante a été ouverte
par le parquet de
Marseille merci pear d'être avec nous
merci beaucoup vous êtes le mari de
mélodie c'est une histoire qu'on suit
depuis le 3 novembre c'est une histoire
complètement folle vous allez nous
raconter ce qui s'est passé le 3
novembre elle sort de la maison dans le
4e arrondissement de Marseille il est
18h15 18h15 ça allait bien elle était
énervée elle était comment quand bah par
le décès de sa mère d'accord c'était
c'était quand c'était le 12 octobre
d'accord elle est parti l'enterrer au
pays au Cap ver d'accord d'cord elle est
revenue le 28 octobre à la maison quand
elle est revenue donc elle se renferm en
elle j'ai pas trop voulu la brquer parce
que je sais ce que c'est moi-même j'ai
perdu mon père il y a quelques années
ouais
donc c'est pas une chose facile perdre
un parent
elle a envoyé un message à sa sœur
Sabrina 18h43 une notre vocale sur snap
c'est ça dis quoi elle lui disait que si
elle voulait la contacter qu'elle
appelait parce que sa sœur est enceinte
donc du
coup voilà elle était disponible si elle
avait besoin d'elle vous étiez où vous à
ce moment-là moi j'étais au travail
d'accord donc pour vous vous aucune
raison de s'inquiéter pour moi aucune
raison de m'inquiéter alors sauf que
vous n'avez très vite plus de réponse
euh pas de nouvell ben je l'ai appelé à
19h15 ouais son téléphone a sonné ouais
je me suis dit qu'elle allait me
rappeler une demi-heure plus tard son
téléphone avait toujours enfin il avait
plus il était éteint quoi à quel moment
vous avez commencé à vous inquiéter
ben dans les alentour de 22h j'ai j'ai
j'ai contacté sa sœur pour savoir si
elle était avec elle j'ai essayé de voir
de mon côté si je pouvais savoir où
est-ce qu'elle était et le lendemain
encore plus et plus les jour il passé au
plus je m'inquiétais vous essayez de la
rappeler plusieurs fois c'est ça
toujours pas et un moment vous a dit il
y a un problème il y a un gros problème
surtout qu'elle est sortie sans rien
sans rien elle avait seulement les
téléphone avec
elle vous appelez tous les hôpitaux les
commiss les hôpitaux je me suis déplacé
dans les hôpitaux montrer la photo je
j'ai essayé de voir pour les
commissariats si était pas en garde à
vue je supposais toutes les choses tu
pouvis avoir et rien rien aucune
nouvelle aucune nouvelle dans la nuit de
vendredi à samedi comment vous avez
comment com vous êtes dans quel état
parce que c'est incroyable vous vous
dites j'avais ma ma femme elle part à
18h40
elle reviens pas je me retrouve 7ette
demis tout seul comment c'était quoi
tour dans le lit je tournais dans le lit
je me je me posais plein de questions je
me demandais qu'est-ce qui se
passait essayé vous étiez à côté de
votre téléphone vous av dit
peut-êtreelle va téléphone téléphone en
plein sonnerie tous les secondes je
quand je me levais je regardais le
téléphone si j'avais pas reçu un appel
alors euh
elle disparaî le vendredi donc le samedi
vous la cherchez partout rien
ouien dimanche pareil vous vous vous
vous appelez la police le lundi je vais
chez la police le lundi oui pourquoi
parce que on m'avait dit que c'était 48
he pour déclarer une disparition
inquiétante d'accord c'est-à-dire que
vous êtes dit avant son ça servait à
rien parce que il vous aurit dit elle va
revenir peut-être voilà donc vous
attendez 48h ces 48 he on devait être
une éternité c'est bon euh vous allez à
la police vous vous dites quoi ben je
leur déclare la disparition que je leur
dis qu'elle est sortie sans rien sans
aucun papier ouais il a étaé en
claquette il é habillé tout en noir là
les les policiers vous disent quoi ils
me disent écoutez ben on va transférer
le dossier à parce que je suis parti
dans le 10e arrendissement pour le faire
la déclaration d'acc donc ils ont
transféré le dossier sur Noa le
lendemain j'ai été contacté par la
police qui eu ont pu voir que le
téléphone avait borné la dernière fois
dans le 11e arrondissement à 19h24
d'accord mais bon un bonnage c'est vaste
ça ça donne pas un point fixe incroyable
donc là 19h24 c'est la dernière fois
qu'on a des nouvelles de de mélodie même
pas des nouvelles
c'est allumé exactement c'est la
dernière fois qu'on a un semblant de de
de
nouvell s persuadé qu'elle allait
rentrer pour la rentrée scolaire de des
enfants c'est ça c'était le lundi
c'était le lundi ou mais pourquoi moment
moment quand vous dites vous étiez
persuadé qu'elle est rentré pour
rentréeol enfant estce qu' moment vous
êtes dit peut-être elle elle a comme
avec le décès de sa maman quelques
semaines plus tôt tout ça vous dit
peut-être elle a elle a voulu un petit
peu faire le le vide c'est ça vra d'être
un peu seul vers le vide ce que je me
suis dit c le meilleur des cas pour moi
à ce momentl
mais c'est vrai que là vous vous
attendez vous attendez et est-ce que la
police a pris tout de suite l'ffire au
sérieux non non au début ils vous ont
dit quoi B il m' r spéciale bon ils
m'ont appelé le lendemain donc je pense
parce que quand même ils ont un peu pris
au sérieux ils ont commencé à faire
leurs recherch
euh après j'ai vu que les choses ont
vraiment bougé cétait à partir de samedi
je crois que N le 11 11 jours après non
on était le 11 donc ça faisait 8 jours
mi-ijour mais c'est vrai parce que
seulement 11 jours après une enquête
pour disparition inquiétante est ouverte
par le parquet de Marseille c'est ça
seulement 11 jours après Gilles est-ce
que c'est c'est la procédure non le
délai est trop long et les premières
heures sont fondamentales dans une
affaire de de disparition donc c'est
vrai qu'il y a déjà le weekend où la
police n'est pas alertée je comprends
tout à fait vos préoccupations puis
après il y a plusieurs jours où la
police ne tente pas de la de la
rechercher donc c'est très compliqué
est-ce que est-ce que justement est-ce
que PEL aurait dû aller voir tout de
suite la police même si c'était avant 48
he ou pas alors l'histoire des 48 he on
a ça dans la tête mais en fait on peut y
aller avant vous auriez pu je vais pas
dire vous auriez dû absolument pas vous
auriez pu mais est-ce que la police à ce
moment-là très vite aurait dit mais
attendez sa maman vient de décéder elle
est peut-être pas bien elle a besoin de
s'ïer la tête je sais pas si ça aurait
changé fondamentalement moi j'ai une
question à vous poser parce que quand
elle sort de chez vous euh on le voit
sur la vidéosurveillance elle est elle
est en tong elle a pas d'affaire sauf
son téléphone est-ce qu'il y a un motif
à cette sortie est-ce qu'elle sort pour
voir quelqu'un voir une amie est-ce
qu'il y a quelque chose qui pe c'est la
question que tout le monde se pose et
vous aussi et vous n'avez pas de réponse
non d'accord elle est pas sortie pour
une raison que l'on connaît en tout cas
pas moi si quelqu'un est la sait je sais
en tout cas c'est pas moi et je pense
qu'une personne serait venue me voir
depuis le temps bien sûr
j'espère les enquêteurs ils vous disent
quoi pe ils me disent plus rien ils sont
sur l'enquête ils peuvent plus me
divulguer il ser même un indice ou même
une information alors on va revenir sur
les éléments qui intriguent avec Pierre
Henry bovis notamment et avec Gilles
donc comme vous l'avez dit vous apprenez
que le bornage du téléphone il a été
borné pour la dernière fois dans le 11e
arrondissement de Marseille à
19h24 euh est-ce qu'elle avait quelque
chose à faire dans ce 11e arrondissement
de Marseille ou pas du tout pas que je
sache c'est pas un secteur qu'on
fréquente souvent nous on est dans le 4e
c'est pas très très loin mais c'est pas
à côté il avz aucun proche qui habite
dans le quartier n avait pas d'amis
là-bas il y a son père qui habite là-bas
mais son père était au pays à ce
moment-là d'accord donc
ou est-ce que vous avez vous avez
également comme la dit Gille pu voir
avoir des nouvelles de des images de de
vidéos de surveillance de l'immeuble euh
et dessus est-ce qu'elle a l'air elle
elle a l'air dans quel état sur les
vidéos de sur elle a l'air hésitante
hésitante d'accord elle a l'air
hésitante donc moi quand j'ai pu
récupéré la vidéo je l'ai vite ramené à
la police le plus rapidement possible et
on la voit sur les caméras vidéo
surveillance de la ville pas du tout
est-ce qu'on a pu la retracer pas ma
connaissance pour le moment pour le
moment il y a cette dernière image puis
comme vous dites le bornage et l'appel à
sa sœur mais il y a pas d'autres traces
à ma connaissance apparemment ils sont
en train de les utiliser hein voilà les
enquêteurs ils ont déjà des images vidé
après prori c'est je suis pas certain
que ça été enregistré sur Marseille mais
ça permettrait effectivement de suivre
son trajet parce qu'il y a une absence
totale ça sera important oui c'est sera
important très important au niveau du
travail elle travaillait ça allait bien
oui ça allait très bien très bien elle
était en train de monter un institut de
beauté avec sa sœur c'est ça donc
c'était son projet donc elle était à
fond dans son projet donc il y a pas de
tu dans ma rue donc pas besoin d'aller
très très
loin et comme vous l'avez dit voilà
niveau perso ça allit un petit peu moins
bien je l'ai vu que ça l'a vraiment ça
l'a vraiment touché la morour de Samar
bien sûr la chose normal c'est maman
elle était comment depuis euh depuis
depuis ce dcès est-ce qu' est-ce qu'elle
vous a dit quelque chose est- qu'elle
vous a dit à un moment j'ai envie de de
tout lâcher j'ai envie de est-ce qu'il y
a eu des signes ou pas du tout non seule
chose que je voyais qu'elle elle se
renfermait beaucoup elle avait pas envie
de sortir pas envie de parler avec les
gens
elle se
renferm vous avez euh deux enfants avec
méod ils ont 15 et 9 ans vous imaginez
bien le dans quel état ils sont
actuellement comment ils ont réagi
comment vous expliquez ça à vos enfants
j'y arrive pas vous arrivez pas c'est
impossible sa même pas quoi leur dire
oui c'est ça ils vous disent quoi vous
disentz elle est où
maman ben les premiers jours oui ouis
donc je savais pas trop quoi leur
répondre leur disait quoi elle va
revenir ouiou jeess les rassurer au
maximum en disant qu'elle va revenir
bien sûr mais là le temps passe de plus
en plus ils doivent se poser des
questions ils m'en parlent même pas
eux-même là ils savent à 9 et 15 ans ils
savent maintenant qu'ilelle est enfin
qu' qu' y a une il pour l'instant on
sait pas où aller et ils vous disent des
choses ils vous disent papa on il m'en
parl pas c'est vrai c'est vraiment il
n'en parl pas du tout non il doit être
dans une tristesse absolue c'est c'est
même pour vous ça doit être très très
compliqué de de de de gérer ça aussi
j'imagine c'est qui me maintine debout
ouais c'est ça ouais aujourd'hui je vous
vois vraiment bah c'est normal très très
affecté euh
et on on se met à votre place on se dit
je sais pas comment on aurait réagi
parce que comme ça une disparition du
jour au lendemain aucune nouvelle les
deux enfants à la maison je sais pas
comment vous trouvez les mots comment
vous trouvez la force pour dans mes
enfants C qui me permett de marcher
aujourd'hui c'est qui me font avancer et
continuer à chercher leur MRE vous y
croyez j'y crois continuez les
recherches bien entendu euh est-ce que
vos enfants il qu vous dites qu's en
parlent pas euh parce que je sais qu' la
plus grande dit tout sur les réseaux
sociaux donc forcément elle sait que
c'est un M où on la recherche de partout
ou
euh est-ce qu'ils ont pu retourner à
l'école et cetera ou ben je préfère les
préserver parce que malheureusement on v
dans un monde où peuvent se moquer de ce
genre de situation exactement exactement
c'est extrêm moi j'ai reçu des appels
horribles non vraiment de gens quoi qui
faisent genre ben elle est elle est
allongé devant moi elle est en train de
pleurer euh je suis à tel endroit on en
numéro masqué bien sûr hein quelle band
des gens qui m' appelai pour me dire oui
bonjour c'est pour commander de la
viande
haché quo non mais vraiment il y a
vraiment des abrutisuse-moi de dire ça
franchement j'ai vraiment on est
vraiment dans un monde d'abru moi je
mets mon numéro parce que je suis
inquiet par rapport à ma compagne bien
sûr il y a des mecs qui font des blagues
mais c'est c'est pas un parmi tant
d'autres oui mais bon même un c'est
c'est inadmissible excusez-moi je
l'imagine donc qu' y a d'état vous êtes
actu plus j'imagine que dès que vous
entendez le téléphone sonner dès que
vous avez un appel tu un numéro que vous
connaissez pas ou é incnu vous dites ça
c'est peut-être une bonne nouvelleelle
ou c'est peut-être une bonne nouvelle
donc je réponds à tous les
appels pierre Henr bovis il faut
prévenir la police tout de suite dans ce
cas-là ou pas c'est ce que disait Gill
verd c'est que c'est très c'est très
difficile à juger si vous voulez et et
en plus il faut absolument pas faire
culpabiliser qui que ce soit là et la
peine est immense mais mais ce qui est
vrai c'est que lorsqu'on a une
disparition qui est subite qui est
inexplicable que ce soit par le contexte
que ce soit par la manière dont la
personne pas
sans aucune raison sans affaires ni rien
on est dans tous les critères qui
caractérisent la disparition inquiétante
mais après c'est c'est c'est au force de
c'est au forces de l'ordre de la
caractériser ainsi pour enprès
déclencher déclencher l'enquête
généralement le les c'est c'est là où on
voit d'ailleurs toute la différence
entre la la pratique et la théorie c'est
qu'en théorie normalement on a une
première phase dite administrative on va
éplucher les comptes bancaires on
regarde les lignes téléphoniques bon et
ensuite après on commence là les vrais
actes d'investigation avec avec des
saisies éventuelles de la
géolocalisation des des des des
perquisitions même pour est-ce qu'
aujourd'hui est-ce qu'aujourd'hui mais
bon là on voit bien que sur la sur la
pratique on est totalement sur un champ
différent euh aujourd'hui comment
comment vous faites pour vous nous avez
dit c'est les enfants qui vous font
tenir Pearl mais vous arrivez à à
trouver le sommeil vous arrivez à
impossible vraiment impossible pas
vraiment après je j'essaie de me reposer
parce que bien sûr vous travaillez le
corps il non non depuis depuis depuis sa
dispartion non vraiment ah ouais plus sa
disparition non vous reste avec les
enfants vous êtes à fond focus sur je
suis plus en train de chercher de
trouver des solutions de comment vous
vous cherchez en fait vous faites
comment vous dis la vérité je tourne
dans la ville je roule ah ouais je suis
en de roues et je je parcours toute la
ville vous avez été forcément dans le
11e arrondissement où elle a été Boré le
11e dans dans dans tous les quartiers de
Marseille vous av interrogé des des des
personnes des person avec une photo
d'elle et C Menz votre propre enquête
quoi voilà et après j'ai beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de monde avec moi
ouais qui m'aide heureusement non donc
voilà je je les remercie tous les jours
et vous avez une idée de de ce qui a pu
lui arriver ou pas du tout non du tout
rien aucune piste rien aucune idée zéro
piste aujourd'hui je serai à l'endroit
où j'aurais une piste vraiment là
aujourd'hui vous vous savez même vous
dites s'il peut je roule à l'aveugle
ouais c'est ça vous êtes inquiet bien
entendu très inquiet plus les jours
passent vous êtes inquiet plus les jours
passent vous dites estce qu'elle va
revenir un
jour sastien cé sur cé on en a parlé
hier une plainte pour deux c'est une
plainte pour des plaintes pourquoi qui
ont été déposé alors il y a une plainte
pour viol qui a été déposé et
l'actualité judiciaire d'aujourd'hui
c'est qu'il y a l'ouverture d'une
enquête
préliminaire ou ouis alors justement le
communiqué d'énergie ils ont publié un
communiqué de presse ils annoncent le
retrait provisoire donc de de de
Sébastien cette décision temporaire
prise d'un commun accord avec Sébastien
cohé est guidé par la nécessité de
garantir la sérénité qui doit prévaloir
face à des démarches judiciaires portant
sur des accusations graves à l'encontre
de Sébastien é animateur de l'émission
sekoé produite par sa société Bioware
production qui les conteste publiquement
l'autorité judiciaire étant saisie il
lui appartient à elle seule de conduire
les investigations dans le respect des
droits des personnes et de la
présomption d'innocence si aucun fait
contraire de la Charte à la charte
éthique du groupe ou attentatoire la
dignité n'avait été signalée le groupe
ennergie a cependant dès le 17 novembre
2023 ordonné une enquête interne cette
enquête toujours en cours et conduite
par un cabinet extérieur et totalement
indépendant pour moi il y a quand même
deux poids de mesure entre on a vu que
M6 soutener son animateur cabinet
externe si c'est un cabinet interne
d'ailleurs il y a des il y a des des
plaignants qui n'ont pas été retenus
dans l'enquête interne donc M6 donc M6
M6 ce qu'il faut savoir c'est qu' M6 a
vraiment vraiment vraiment soutenu son
animateur à fond et ennergie G c'est
c'est moins c'est moins net moi moi ce
que j'aime dans le communiqué que je
trouve bien structuré c'est le troisème
mot 3è ligne sérénité c'estàdire que
s'il vient s'il vient à l'antenne s'il
reste à l'antenne dans une émission
comme ça de libre antenne je trouve que
la sérénité même pour lui n'est pas
garantie donc je trouve que c'est une
bonne décision et ce qui est intéressant
aussi Cyril c'est que Energy a déclenché
l'enquête dès le 17 novembre c'estàd
qu'ils sont partis avant c'est-à-dire
que Energy a envie de savoir
effectivement ce qui s'est passé et ça
je trouve que c'est intéressant de leur
part voilà alors après on peut dire il
lâche Sébastien cohet mais lui
franchement moi j'avais échanger hier
avec son entourage il est combatif ça va
lui permettre aussi de se consacrer à ce
lourd dossier pour se défendre voilà
donc là il est il est aventure on va on
a des nouveaux éléments dans un instant
juste là-dessus Myriam palongb les
éléments les pardon les les les éléments
bah les éléments c'est que vous en avez
dit une bonne partie hein c'est que donc
il y a cette enquête préliminaire qui
vient d'être déclenchée par le parquet
de bourenbrest qui va donc suivre des il
y a des investigations qui vont suivre
sous la responsabilité du procureur de
la République évidemment la plaignante
va être à nouveau entendu coé va
également également être entendu on va
revenir sur cette affaire et sur les
messages user sur les réseaux sociaux
euh myiam et et Gill donc c'est ça qui a
mis le feu au poudre et on va revenir
sur le témoignage de cette de cette
jeune fille voilà qui a témoigné hier
sur BFM TV ave elle était on on la
voyait pas hein on va voir ça dans un
instant sur les les messages diffusés
sur les réseaux sociaux myiam et Gilles
oui il y a énormément de de de de
messages depuis depuis le 13 octobre où
l'affaire a été révélée sur sur les
réseaux sociaux d'ailleurs d'abord la la
la la plaignante mais même tout un tas
de de de jeunes femmes une certaine
Mathilde qui a parlé longuement sur les
réseaux sociaux il y en a plein d'autres
et tous ces témoignages vont être
évidemment apportés à la plainte il se
dit même que d'autres plaintes
pourraient être déposées par la suite
alors pas forcément par des jeunes
filles mineures mais que des plaintes
devrait suivre en plus de celles qui ont
déjà été déposées sur les sur les les
les échanges avec cette jeune fille il y
a une chose qui pose question sur les
échanges son voilà jug alors justement
on les a les échanges on peut ils ont
été révélés partout après on sait pas
s'il y a des trucs qui ont été effacés
pas effacés en fait ce qui pose question
c'est les horaires c'est queé parlerait
tout seul pendant 2 3 heures et se
répondrait à
lui-même l'application avec laquelle
sont envoyé ses messages che WhatsApp et
on sait qu'on peut supprimer des
messages donc là c'est vrai qu'on a
l'impression regardz entre 18h25 et 22h
que coé parle seul ça peut poser
question sur l'éventualité que certains
messages auraient été supprimés dans
cette rond toi toi qui tu as travaillé
en plus avec ouais moi je pense que
comme Guillaume je pense qu' là-dedans
il y a des messages qui qui ont été
effacés alors j'espère qu'il a tous les
messages j'espère que il va il va dire
comme il a dit qu'il va qui va prouver
qu'il est qu'il est innocent dans cette
histoire et que c'est une entreprise de
déstabilisation parce que ça me paraît
ça me paraît quand même curieux et mais
mais si il a fait des choses mal il
faudra qu'il soit puni mais moi je comme
Guillaume je dis que là il manque quand
même beaucoup je vois pas je vois pas
moi moi je le connais cé c'est un ami je
le connais je le vois pas parler de
19h30 à 22h tout seul comme ça envoyer
des à bombarder si ça répond pas ça
répond pas ça me paraît ça me paraît
bizarre et sur des extraits que j'ai vu
sur sur BFM j'ai aussi d'autres extraits
sur YouTube ou a dit ou a a dit le
contraire justement vous allez nous en
parler parce que vous allez nous en
parler on va voir les extraits vous
allez nous dire Ron ce qui vous dérange
que hier elle était pour la première
fois la télé là la plignante elle a
raconté comment aurait eu
lieu le premier contact avec ko qu'elle
dénonce
regardeou je suis montée dans sa chambre
et il me dit bah écoute fais-moi s
fais-moi écouter ta maquette radio il y
a pas de problème donc il s'est mis à
côté de moi et c'est à ce momentl en
fait où il a où il a baissé son pantalon
de vraiment quelques centimètres absol
presque ici quoi il a absolument tout
sorti et c'est là c'est à ce moment-là
qu'il m'a dit c'est comme ça qu'on
réussit dans la radio il faut que tu le
fasses je l'ai regardé droit dans les
yeux et je lui ai
dit je peux pas et il m'a dit si tu veux
réussir dans la radio il faut le faire
donc moi à 15 ans bah c'est ce que j'ai
exécuté et ma sœur elle a continué à
m'appeler et c'est ce qui m'a sauvé
parce que il s'est il a arrêté et il m'a
dit écoute ta sœur elle va finir par
monter on descend
on va voir d'autres extraits dans dans
un instant oui alors ce ce qui est
intéressant c'est qu'il y a une vraie
offensive de la part de la plignante
médiatique c'estàdire qu'elle est
d'abord sur les réseaux elle estime
qu'elle n'est pas entendue ensuite elle
porte plainte et là elle apparaît et de
l' vie de l'entourage de Sébastien cohet
ça va alimenter le fait que pour eux ce
soit une entreprise de déstabilisation
parce que ça va très vite mais attention
il faut respecter la parole de la
plignante et nous ne pouvons pas prendre
partie du tout he voilà aujourd'hui en
tout cas la plignante elle est
le fait d'avoir d'avoir parlé de et et
de de d'avoir dit ce qu'elle avait à
dire c'était quelque chose qu'elle
gardait en elle depuis pas mal d'années
elle se sent beaucoup mieux d'autant
plus qu'il y a d'autres témoignages qui
vientnent de corroborer son expérience
absolument etou il y a un autre élément
qui est pointé par ceux qui défend de Cé
c'est que cette plignante était donc une
fan de Cé de ses émissions et qu'elle
aurait encore une fois ça justifie rien
du tout mais qu'elle aurait continué à
poster des photos avec lui en compagnie
de Cé sur sa photo de profil avec lui
donc ceux qui défendent cé disent mais
regardez elle était toujours en bon
terme avec lui puisquelle l'ffiché sur
sa photo de profil mais ça veut dire que
mais l'emprise tu sais ça existe alors
elle explique que depuis sa vie est un
calvaire elle a d'ailleurs fait elle a
dit plusieurs tentatives de suicide
regardez
j'ai essayé de mettre fin à mes jours
que ma sœur elle portait elle portait
ses ses accusations depuis depuis les
fait et je je l'ai fait passer pour une
menteuse et j'ai en fait j'ai détruit ma
famille ou je dirais plus qu'il a
détruit ma famille j'ai conscience de la
présomption d'innocent j'ai conscience
que les gens peuvent croire ce qu'il moi
je veux juste être libéré de ce poids de
d'avoir presque détruit ma famille
d'avoir presque détruit ma vie parce
qu'aujourd'hui j'ai 25 ans donc c'était
c'était il y a 1 an et il y a 10 ans je
me dis que pendant t ce temp je me suis
détruite et et je me suis empêché de
vivre réellement ma vie c'est horrible
c'est terrible ouis bon le témoignage
est évidemment très fort on va pas le le
minimiser après une des oui des
interrogations de l'entourage de de
Sébastien C c'est sur l'âge alors c'est
ça alors Miriam et Miriam alors sur
l'âge c'est c'est un peu compliqué parce
que effectivement quand elle a connu cé
elle avait 15 ans c'était donc pendant
ce fameux rendez-vous à Disneyland et
quand elle a été à Genève elle avait
visiblement 16 ans puisque elle est née
en septembre et que du coup voilà y a
des espèces d'incohérence dans son
témoignage où un coup elle dit qu'elle
avait 15 ans un coup elle dit qu'elle
avait 16 ans et c'est quand même assez
important notamment pour la peine
encourue à ce moment-là pour viol oui
c'est très important même parce que bien
évidemment l'enquête va déterminer la
cohérence ou l'incohérence des
témoignages et s'il y a des incohérences
sur l'âge effectivement ça peut après
fragiliser exactement un témoignage
d'autant que on le disait ensuite il y a
permanence de si je puis dire la la
relation ou en tout cas la publication
de photos le fait que cet été la
plignante souhaitait d'après l'entourage
de Sébastien C le rejoindre donc est-ce
qu'il y a une obsession pour lui c'est
ce que en tout cas va plaider
l'entourage de Sébastien cet que cette
jeune femme en fait n'a cessé de vouloir
être proche de lui voilà elle dit
qu'elle a dû être hospitalisée et ce
traitement antidépresseur depuis
plusieurs années regardez sur l'âge
pardon depuis tout ça je suis suivie
déjà par un psychiatre une psychologue
et qui m'aide énormément j'ai été au
hospitalisé à plusieurs reprises je suis
sous traitement sous antidépresseur sous
traitement pour dormir la nuit c'est des
cauchemars que je fais et que et que je
continue à faire à l'heure actuelle donc
maintenant j'attends juste de pouvoir
m'en sortir pour pouvoir prendre ses
traitements parce qu'avec ces
traitements en fait on sent plus rien on
fait plus rien et on sent complètement
vide alors je me dis que justement c'est
peut-être la seule chose aussi qui m'a
poussé à porter la plainte parce que
j'avais peur et pendant ce temps-là j'ai
réussi à pouvoir faire les choses Raymon
vous disz c'est poignant c'est poignant
comme témoignage parce que là la la nana
là moi moi je la crois à 200 % sauf que
moi j'ai eu des textos j'ai eu des
messages j'ai eu des dates qui collent
pas du tout notamment où elle a 18 ans
quand elle est sur une émission sur Fun
Radio quand je vois ça je me dis c'est
c'est poignant c'est c'est fort ce qu'
ce qui est arrivé à cette n mais d'un
autre côté quand je reçois les textos et
les preuves qu'on me dit regarde c'est
une mytho c'est une mytho j'ai pas
l'impression que c'est la même personne
j'ai pas l'impression qu'on parle de la
même personne parliez vous parliez
instant de truc sur Facebook de post sur
Facebook et de et de et de témignag vous
dit pour vous il y a des y a des il y a
des dates qui collent pas où elle passe
dans une émission de radio sur Fun Radio
chez ano et et Marion où elle dit
qu'elle a 18 ans donc ça colle pas du
tout avec les les dates qu'on me dit là
mais mais quand je vois ça je je vois le
témoignage je me dis c'est il s'est
passé un truc et en même temps j'ai j'ai
j'ai j'ai du mal par rapport à ce qu'on
me dit alors ils réservent leur leur
défense à la police et j'espère que ça
va aller très vite alors justement on va
avoir des infos dans un instant a hein
de ce qui se passe actuellement non je
voulais juste préciser que sur l'âge le
parquet a ouvert une Formation
Judiciaire euh une enquête préliminaire
pardon oui pour viol sur enfants de plus
de 15 ans plus 15 15 ans donc ça veut
dire que eux ils retiennent un âge
au-delà de 15 ans entre 15 et 18 ans il
y a deux deux plaintes une pour mineurs
de plus de 15 ans sur le fait queelle
avait peut-être moins de 16 ans ou 15
ans après je j' en te dire même là je
m'en fous c'est le viol je veux même pas
qu'il ait viol en fait là je m'en fous
qu' qu'elle estit 17 ans ou qu'elle
estit 20 ans c'est le viol c'est
l'appellation viol j'espère que ça va
vite sortir je ve dire par que je vois
pas je le vois pas je le vois pas violer
en fait donc là je limite je m'en fous
c'est le viol moi qui m'intéresse vois
l'un des bookurs de ce fameux épisode à
Genève qui m'a effectivement confirmé la
présence de cette jeune femme et qui m'a
quand même aussi confirmé la prés le
fait que cé avait fait monter dans sa
chambre d'hôtel après il a pas pu me
décrire ce qui s'était passé dans la
chambre d'hôtel puisqu'il n'y était pas
mais mais en tout cas il m'a confirmé
cet événement alors elle raconte qu'elle
veut juste qu'il paye pour ce qu'il a
fait ce qu'il a dit dans le témoignage
hier oui et d'ailleurs on va regarder
peu importe ce qui se passe peu importe
ce qui qui se dit peu importe qui qui
fait quoi je veux juste être reconnu en
tant que tel et que lui il passe il paye
pour ce qu'il a fait qu'il arrête d'en
faire d'aut de victimes c'est tout ce
que je demande
oui d'ailleurs pour revenir sur
l'enquête préliminaire parce que c'est
très intéressant il faut peut-être juste
rappeler ce qu'il y a une enquête
préliminaire une enquête préliminaire ça
veut dire que on va enquêter pour voir
s'il y a ou non une infraction hein on
en est au stade où tout le monde va être
entendu pour déterminer s'il y a des
indices qui établissent l'existence
d'une infraction pénale effectivement
cette enquête elle est ouverte pour viol
sur mineur de plus de 15 ans et viol
parce que la plainte porte donc sur deux
viols le viol au moment à Genève donc au
moment où cette jeune femme était
mineure et un viol en 2022 donc voilà il
y a beaucoup d'écarts entre les deux c
entre les de de viols 8 ans il y a oui
un peu moins mais voilà ça c'est
intéressant c'est il y a il y a deux
viols et c'est ouvert à Bour enbresse
parce que la jeune femme a porté plainte
dans l'un où elle réside voilà au niveau
judiciaire où on en est c'est le début
de l'action judiciaire ou puis après il
va y avoir aussi des expertises
psychologiques de la jeune femme Koé va
être entendu il va pouvoir aussi
apporter ses preuves ENF il y a plein de
choses qui vont être déterminantes
pendant l'enquête ils pourront
éventuellement être confrontés aussi
effectivement il auraement
alors justement la défense elle en est
où Gill la défense de Sébastien cet
c'est de dire que c'est une machination
c'est de dire que c'est une
déstabilisation c'est de dire
globalement alors et disent-il nous le
prouverons qu'il n'y a rien alors
effectivement là où on ne peut pas
répondre et Raymond les évoquait c'est
sur le contenu la réalité l'existence de
ces SMS moi j'ai pas l'info et ça
l'entourage de Sébastien C et lui-même
le réserve pour la police pour les
enquêteurs mais sur le fond ils disent
qu'il n'y a rien c'est c'est que
Sébastien cohet ne dévie pas de sa ligne
qui est de dire il n'y a pas eu de viol
et je le prouverai voilà donc on a deux
versions qui sont extrêmement
contradictoires c'est souvent le cas
dans ce type d'affaires et ce sera à la
police de démêler le vrai du faux bien
entendu mais quel serait le but de
déstabiliser qu'une jeune femme comme ça
de 22 ans enfin ce serait quoi son but
en fait ça que je comprends pas ce que
dit l'entourage de Sébastien C c'est que
c'est une tentative globale de
déstabilisation de lui qui sort en ce
moment et cetera voilà moi je ne fais
que relater ce que eux estiment
poupette de Kenza ni tout lien avec
l'agression mais il y a un contentieux
entre aquabeb et Poupet Kenza puisque
aquabeb depuis quelques temps avait
dénoncé les pratiques les pratiques
commerciales de Poupet Kenza notamment
le fait qu'elle continue des placements
de produits alors que elle était avec
son enfant à l'hôpital on est d'accord
là-dessus donc aquabeb avait dénoncé ça
et si mes informations sont bonnes vous
aviez même agi euh de telle manière
qu'un partenariat soit rompu entre poupé
de Kenza et une firme c'est ça donc elle
a perdu un partenariat je vous incrimine
pas du tout hein mais elle a perdu un
partenariat et donc c'est vrai qu'il y a
une ranqueur mais pour le moment comme
dit maître il y a pas de lien établi
entre cette ranqueur ce contentieux et
l'agression il faut noter que les
policiers ont pris très au sérieux
l'agression et effectivement ils ont
plusieurs pistes et ils sont décidés à
aller au bout de toutes les piste avec
notamment la vidéosurveillance et tous
les messages préliminaires qui ont
abouti à ce que son adresse soit
dévoilée oui non moi je je suis vraiment
évidemment désolé de te voir dans cet
état là de cet état là et il ne faut que
condamner les agressions dont tu as été
victime j'ai juste une question à te
poser sans aucune animosité est-ce que
ça te fait prendre conscience du danger
du métier que tu exerces qui est une
sorte de journalistme people 2.0 parce
qu'il y a plusieurs personnes qui te
menass à plusieurs reprises est-ce que
ça te fait peur pour la suite est-ce que
tu dis peut-être que ce que je fais est
un peu trop dangereux qui peut m'arriver
ce genre de chos encore une fois alors
il y a qu'en France où il y a cette
impunité envers aquababe c'està dire que
alors moi on on peut tout me faire
c'est-à-dire qu'on peut me frapper on
peut me séquestrer on peut diffuser des
vidéos de moi tout nu sur internet mais
quand il s'agit d'autre presse
c'est-à-dire public closeur ou n'importe
ça le ça leur fait rien donc non je
comprends pas pourquoi moi quand il
s'agit de moi aquabab aniziuni on a le
droit de venir à mon domicile me
séquestrer me frapper non je non je
comprends pas et non j'arrêterai pas mon
métier pour pour ça mais oui euh au même
titre que Guillaume pareil je je trouve
que c'est terrible ce qui tit arrivé et
je le remets pas du tout en cause et
cetera mais juste euh bah j'ai bien
compris du coup que tu n'arrêteras pas
de faire ce que tu fais comme travail et
c'est pas du tout méchant ce que je veux
te dire mais est-ce que ça te fait pas
prendre conscience là le cyber
harcèlement que tu dis recevoir est-ce
que ça te fait pas prendre conscience
que tu es aussi des fois l'élément
déclencheur de
beaucoup non mais je je déonce foisces
excuse non bah excuse-moi ma chérie mais
à partir du la vérité c'est que tu as
déjà dénoncé des faux des faits me
concernant qui était faux et du coup tu
n'avais pasou ça c'est ta version des
faits après ça reste ta version des
fait par pou k on parle
de parles de tonire pas du tout je parle
pas de moi je veux juste te dire que je
sais
deéresse pas TR tu VO je sais juste de
sources je peux terminer je sais de
sources sûr que des fois tu dénonces des
faits sans savoir s'ils sont véridiques
ou non et c'est ce qui fait de toi selon
moi un journaliste qui est pas forcément
très très bon mais ça exuse-moi madame
je me Peret parce que je suis son avocat
je comprends ce que vous dites
concernante c'est pasjet aujourd'hui je
comprends personnel c'est absolument pas
le sujet aujourd'hui parce que à partir
du moment et je vous fais pas le
reproche où vous dites oui il s'est
passé ça mais est-ce que vous ne pensez
pas vous avez pas une espèce de remise
en question un c'est pas le moment de je
crois pas que ce soit le lieu et tr très
sincèrement après ce qu' s'est
passé non mais je comprends et vraiment
je je trouve ça terrible ce qu' lui
arrivé j'en suis vraiment navré je dis
juste que effectivement il y a beaucoup
de cyber harcèlement il y a des gens qui
ont vécu des choses dramatiques à la
suite de choses qui on été et juste
est-ce que ça te fait ouvrir les yeux
c'est la seule chose que je pose comme
question et je pense que ce soit je n'ai
jamais cyber harcelé quelqu'un je sens
des articles de Prut des choses je ne
suis pas responsable du cyber
harcèlement qui est engré engendré
pardon ensuite à la diffusion de mes
articles je ne suis pas responsable je
sors une information comme n'importe
quelle presse stirait une information
tout simplement et je rajoute qu'à C il
y a pas de procédure vous dit non mais
tu as quand même il faut dire la réalité
on s'en on sta parler au téléphone à
l'époque c'est vrai tu en es conscient
je pense tu as un fond de commerce qui
peut poser des problèmes il y a des gens
qui n'ont pas envie de certains éléments
de leur vie privée dévoilé on
pascems que on n'accepte
pas je suis son avocat je suis pas son
premier fan je trouve qu'il fait des
choses parfois bien parfois des choses
moins bien là n'est pas la question je
suis d'accord avec vous peut-être que
vous le réinviterez plus tard quand il y
aura des problèmes sur ce qu'il pourrait
sortir ou pas je dis que dire que ce qui
lui est arrivé peut avoir une certaine
forme de d'influence sur ce qui son son
métier je vous dis attention je vous dis
attention parce que ce n'est pas parce
que il dévoile parfois des information
conséquence réelle qui est regrettable
évidemment mais c'est une conséquence ce
n pas une conséquence P pas une
conséquence oui mais j'ai une question
sur je voudrais revenir sur sur
l'affaire et la violence parce que les
agresseurs étaient trois c'était
prémédité ils avaient donc une arme de
point et un cutterur est-ce que ils ont
été mis en fuite parce que aquabb a eu
la présence d'esprit d'appeler son ami
et j'ai vu que vous aviez vous songiez à
éargir l'enquête à tentative de meurtre
donc ma question elle est est-ce qu'ils
étaient venus pour tuer aquabb écoutez
je je ne sais pas je ne sais pas dans
leur fort intérieur pour l'instant
l'enquête elle est ouverte pour des
violences volontaires avec trois
circonstances aggravantes c'est un délit
qui est extrêmement grave qui est prévu
par l'article 222- 13 du code pénal et
qui est qui est punissable de 7 ans
d'emprisonnement et 100000 € d'amende
maintenant l'enquête et est ont remise
merci les policiers parce
qu'effectivement il font un gros travail
sur ce dossier il est maintenant sous
protection c'est-à-dire que il y a un
vrai danger on verra dans l'enquête si
effectivement et j'espère qu'on retrouve
les auteurs qui sont encore en fuite il
y avait une intention de donner la mort
on verra pour l'instant c'est ouvert
pour violence aggravée par trois
circonstances moi moi si si je puux me
permettre je dans la oui oui c'est c'est
quoi votre r non parce que là là
aujourd'hui on est pas fait on n pas là
pour faire son procès je dis il on est
là pour parler de l'agression il
reviendra une autre fois on verra voilà
mais là c'est c'est vrai là là les gars
vous C vous croyez où
mais je pense que rien justifie qu' se
so fait agress exactement c'est ça non
mais les mecs rien justifie qu'il se
soit fait agresser donc arrêtez avec
voilà on en reparlera peut-être une
prochaine fois comm dit sû c'est un jeun
homme de 25 ans qui s'est quand même
fait braquer avec une arme de point et
qui s'est fait là il a la casquette et
voyez voyez le
traumatisme il s'est fait braquer et on
lui a cassé la tête il y a des ITT qui
ont été proncé je ve dire c'est ça le
sujet jamais dit qu'il était
légitime les Mei dire ça
dire dis uneutreis maintenantz est dans
un qui
estile non mais c'est vrai c'est pas le
procès
de par s de
truc désolé pour lui c'est horrible je
pense que c'est quelqu'un sincèrement
qui a du talent et et je pense qu'il
pourrait autrement et moi je vous le dis
parce que ça m'est arrivé voilà avant
quand j'étais dans une autre relation en
couple et que j'avais été infidèle voilà
je le dis j'en ai rien à [__] il
voulait sortir des trucs à mon à mon
encontre je lui ai dit vas-y fais-le
mais c'est pas bien et il le sait voilà
c'est dommage de jouer sur ces trucs là
parce qu'on a tous des dossiers on a
tous tous des choses à se reprocher et
avoir ça quand fond de commerce
malheureusement il y a des gens qui vont
mal réagir et qui vont commettre des
agressions ce qui est encore une fois
extrêmement pas le sujet ce soir
Guillaume là tu confonds tout là tu
confonds tout
gu suj ce soir Ren
justifie je suis désolé pour lui encore
une c'est
me l' de dire si tu fais vraiment et
beaucoup de merde à un moment donné tu
récoles et donc tu te fais agresser chez
toi tu peux de sujets
différents de sujets différents non si
au départ il y a des fake news o il y a
une haine qui part d'un côté rien ne
justifie ce qui lui est arrivé je suis
vraiment moi je ne connaissis je suis
vraiment très très désolé mais je pense
que ça fait partie du débat quand même
si je peux vous répondre là-dessus c'est
Monsieur cardose Je me permets en
répondant comme ça vous êtes déjà les
services de police qui disent c'est
parce que il est aqu qui s'est fait
agresser c'est parce que il y a des fake
news qui se fait agresser vous savez pas
saz
RZ merci les Ch
esth tout merci d'être êre là on va
revenir sur votre vidéo vous allez
répondre parce que tout le monde se
demande voilà tout le monde a donné son
son avis ici voilà donc vous avez donné
le le sein à votre neveu parce que c'est
le fils de votre sœur niè niè ex tu vois
euh votre niè voilà et donc ça a fait un
buz incroyable voilà donc voilà donc qui
est choqué ce qu'on vous a demandé
choqué pas choqué on vous demande
également chez vous à 20h41 on en direct
Diane moi je suis un peu choqué mais en
fait dans l'absolu ça m'aurait pas
dérangé s'il y avait eu un message avec
voà ouais c'est ça si vous aviez dit
dedans bah que c'était justement parce
que vous voulez alliter être la mère
d'allaitement et cetera pourquoi pas
c'est un vrai message et ça peut être
intéressant justement pour les gens qui
ne s'y connaissent pas là juste comme ça
j'ai l'impression qu'effectivement c'est
un appel au buzz parce que on se doute
qu'il y a pas de lait là tout de suite
ça pas été travaillé avant si vous dites
en plus que le bébé il est mort enfin il
est né il y a pas longtemps je suis un
peu surprise de du snap juste pris comme
ça parceil est vraiment étéé comme ça
symbolique mais symbolique mais sans
message moi et ma sœur la mère de
l'enfant d'ailleurs
expliquer juste montrer ça il y a pas
grand chose s avit vraent moi j'urais
dans la story justement j'avais fait une
story j'ai pas fait que ce snap j'avais
fait toute une story et j'ai fait au
moins 50 snap puis j'ai fait cette vidéo
de 3 secondes je pensais pas qu'elle
allait faire autant de buzz mais pour
moi c'était pas un truc de de malade de
faire ça alors vous allez répondre un
instant tout le monde aussi un tout vous
avez changé d'avis vous oui oui j'ai
entendu Géraldine et c'est inacceptable
de son côté donc voilà bravo tout bra
alors Ron toi tu es choqué toi ouais je
suis choqué parce que c'est faire du
buzz avec le petit ça sert à rien sa
sœur elle peut allter si sa sœ VZ pas
alliter mais sa sœur elle peut alliter
là c'est juste pour pour se montrer sur
Instagram pour faire bien elle est jeune
moi moi je suis pas dans le délire des
des influenceurs ni des influenceuses je
trouve ça je trouve ça dommage il y a
même pas de lait il aura du lait encore
le
lait c'est magnifique il y a M pas de
la du lait pourir du lait faut commencer
c'est comme les de habitu
hab mer ta sœur elle a du lait elle fera
du lait tuas rien
à fait un enfant c'est pas ton enfant
continue à fairees stor coucou les
loulous laisse la maternéiss la
maternité laisse tomber la
[Applaudissements]
maternitéch il est là t il y a rien qui
so laiss tranquille laiss tranquille le
petit il va grandir tranquillement laiss
de vos conneries là en plus ouais en
plus il y a un truc obsè c'estàd que
d'abord moi je trouve que un nouveau né
c'est pas un
gadget en sex toy carrément ouais non en
fait il y a un côté le nouveaué en fait
tu tu l'utilis
enftilise vous l'utilisez pour le mettre
sur votre nichon qui est
par et en plus vous sexualisez vous
sexualisez
l'allaitement j'ai écris oh j'aime trop
ça j'écris quoi il y a rien arrêtez
arrêtez il y a que Gilles Verdez et
Jean-Michel mer qui sonont assez Nigo
pour tomber dans le panneau
excuse-moi
ça pardon vous banalisez le fait de
donner le sein quand on est la sœur de
quelqu'un ça veut dire quoi c'est où la
limite après c'est la mère la tante la
grand-mère c'est
PASC
N a le même s elle m'autorise à le faire
pour sa fille qui VI
la fille elle me dit oui toute la
famille est là je fais mon petit de 3
secondes mais je cherche le buz oui fais
il fais-le laisse le téter dans le vide
il faut bien commencer pour avoir du
laitrte c'est pas sa m elle va pas venir
tous les jours pour le faire
pourquoi demain vous y allez demain je
crois
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
elle y va demain elle y va maisement
tant c'est beau comme image on l'a
désacralisé on a arrêté justement d' ce
tabou le problème c'est que justement en
faisant ça rem sur la vidéo j'ai
sexualisé quelque ch pas sexualisé mais
moi je dis simplement que là pour le
coup il y a pas de message qu c'est
vraiment juste montr pour montrer
l'allement m c'est beau c'est mainant il
y a plus de table on est fier de dire
qu'on peut le faire de manière publique
mais là étant donné que c'est pas ton
enfant tu ne peux pas donner de lait je
vois pas le message vous allez
l'allitter ou pas finalement alors
qu'est-ce qui décidé
l' aujourd'hui vous êtes passé à
l'hôpital pour qu'il vous su oui Mad
mais on peut vous avez démonté de l'IT
là déjà ou pas encore elle va y aller
elle va demain
croyz à ce qu'onous dit là fa Tu Vi dire
tu viens dire c'est intime c'est comme
donner le
c'est
direuent pas
Snapper Mo je
trouve si vous devz répondre à tout le
monde vous diriez quoi tout comment si
vous deviez répondre à tout le monde
vousz qu'on ma sœ parce que ma sœur qui
est la mère de l'enfant elle aimerait
parler d'accord vu que c'est son enfant
qui est concerné bien sûr d'accord et
sinon qu'est-ce que vous voulez dire
parce qu'on va on est en train d'appeler
votre sœur elle va
in j'aimerais dire que j'ai eu l'accord
de ma sœur queil y en a chez certaines
personnes c'est culturel que c'est
symbolique que la sœur ou que la mère de
la personne qui vient d'accoucher donne
l'enfant donne le sein à l'enfant qui
vient de naître c'est pas du tout sexuel
c'est pas du tout pervers je cherchais
pas le buzz j'ai fait 70000 snap le jour
même où la magè est né mais c'est ça
qu'on a retenu elle s'appelle comment
vre sœur Cupidon Leana leanaana Leana je
crois non mais il y a sa sœur oui bon
bonsoir tu as dit quoi bonsoir bonsoir
bonsoir bonsoir ça alors ça va bien oui
ça va et vous alors dites-nous ce que
vous vouliez dire félicitations déjà bah
félicitations déjà félicitations déjà
oui félicitations pour
moi bravo bravo
alors allô oui oui j'ai accouché il y a
moins de 48h et mon enfan est déjà dans
une SA Twitter je comprends pas
trop en sachant que j'ai autorisé ma
sœur à allitter mon enfant donc je vois
pas en quoi c'est un problème c'est mon
enfant d'accord donc vous voilà donc
vous lui avez donné l'autorisation vous
voilà donc vous voyez pas le problème en
fait c'est ça c'est ça voilà donc voilà
donc elle dit je comprends pas que mon
enfant il soit déjà dans une sauce sur
Twitter sa elle elle est à fond dans les
réseaux
sociaux son enfant bah vous dites que
vous comprenez pas que votre enfant il
soit déjà dans la sauce sur Twitter 48
he mais V votre sœur elle est connue
c'est une influenceuse pourquoi vous la
laissez vous filmez votre bébé mais
alors attendez attendez vous êtes obligé
de comprendre qu'il est dans la SAU
écoutez je vois pas en quoi l'itement
c'est quelque chose do sexualiser en
fait sexualisé moi j'ai pas sexualisé je
réponds juste à votre question vous
dites que mon enfant est déjà dans la
sauce c'est normal votre s il va la SA
écoutez vous sexualise ça parce que j'ai
rien sexualisé moi je je sexualise pas
un enfant avec le sein d'une dame qui
lui donne le qui sexualis ça
que je fais ça pour les vu parce que
c'est mes seins parce
que moi j'ai parlé ah c'est ici alors
j'ai dismi le vieux con
entendu JeanMichel Jean-Michel quand
vous entendez ça vous dites quoi vous ah
non mais moi je trouve ça incroyable di
excuse-moi tu dis c'est quoi le message
quand tu fais Miss Univers c'est quoi le
message aux extraterrestres je suis
célibataire c'est quoi il y a pas de
message tu vois si tu fais quelque
choseose là tu confonds tout non mais
encore une fois l'allêement moi ça me
choque pas je trouve ça beau il faut le
montrer fa faut justement rendre
c'est le fait que tues sans rien quo là
c'est juste posté comme ça donc on
comprend pas est-ce que je comme ça je n
pas la nourriture des fois bah il y a
pas de message
rien qume y a une naissance qui en
arrivé et C les gens
il cel choqu les gens j' a fait plein
d'autres j'ai pas eu que ça j'ai écrit
des longs textes mêmec qu'est-ce que
vous ça vous choque non en fait moi je
trouve ça m'aurait pas dérangé si vous
ne l'aviez pas publié et je trouve ça
obsène de le publier aurait pas été là
Onura pas fait le sujet voilà qu'est-ce
que tu es con mon
Zac non parce que en fait on est dans
une immense hypocrisie depuis tout à
l'heure la réalité c'est que ça vous
choque uniquement parce que c'est
diffusé donc je suis pas con mon cher
Verdez parce que ça en soi ça me choque
pas du tout puisque ma première réaction
a été de dire moi en fait je m'en fiche
parce que il y a il y a il y a il y a
150 ans il y avait des orphelinas il y
avait des nourrices qui le faisaient et
qui le et c'était pas comme l'expliqué
tout à l'heure Jean-Michel c'était la
cousine c'était des membres de la
famille donc en soi c'est pas quelque
chose qui me choque après je sais pas
s'il faut avoir un enfant pour P le
faire disant so pas diffusé tu au fait
que les
G nous pour
les quelque
chose
oui que j'avis
à r ch àout coms merci en tout cas en
gros tout ce que je vis dire c'est que
mon enfant c'est pas un jouet que il y a
pas besoin de
faire [__] c'est c'est contradictoire
de ouf all oui on est toujours là c'est
contradictoire de de faire un drama pour
un Plon ok ok
bon un tuto merci non mais c'est bon on
va
parler un téton
d'accord bah merci je VO un tuto
tut merci
là
tout on va laisser on va laisser tout
àtis se voilà terminer clôturer ce ce ce
débat combien important bah oui mais
c'est vrai bah oui bah oui bah oui c'est
important oui c'est important oui tout à
fous en vrai oui tout à que j'ai la
corord de la merè c'est OK donner le
sein c'est pas sexuel c'est pas pervers
c'est pas pour les vues c'est pas pour
MIM c'est pas un sexoy bien sû bien sûr
il y a rien de bizarre c'est familial
c'est symbolique c'est culturel chez
nous et c'est tout c'est tout c'est vrai
que c'est très ménagère ou non mais
c'est vrai donc ça va vous allez refaire
oui quand
bah je sais pas quand
ou c'est parce que c'est par que par
rapport à ce qu'on a dit si c'est une
logique juste
buzez plusurs fois çaz à
chais vous allez ref que qui croit
partirer produit partout en France et en
Europe
tout Oui 68 % des gens sont
choqués encore du mauvais côté vous
répondez tout on a dit que la terre
était ronde il y avait 99 % des gens qui
étaient choqués sur terre pas de ma
faute excuse-moi tu as d'autres
argumentsci qu'est-ce que vous V vous
voudriez nous dire en ha de la fin tout
ti tout il la vie allez je suis contente
pour ma niè voilà la vie voilà comment
s'app Leana mais tout le monde s'appelle
Lana mais non mais elle l'a déjà dit
tout à l'heure non mais ah je croyais
que c'était votre sœur ah sœ c'est MAA
par je croyais tout le monde
s'appait je pensais que sa sœur
s'appelait Leana aussi je dis en fait
vous vous appelez vous appelez Leana en
vrai aussi moi non non Jessie Jessie
d'accord on embrasse en tout cas votre
sœur et et Lana merci en tout cas
d'avoir été avec nous et bon c'est rien
de grave hein non c'est rien de grave
vous savez pas si j'ai du lait ou pas
vra alors moi je ne veux pas le savoir
euh personnellement voilà moi je ne veux
pas le savoir ou pas je j'ai posé la
question en premier je ne veux pas le
savoir VO c'était une très belle
question avez-vous du lait on vous la
reposera certainement très couramment
merci donc voilà merci merci en tout cas
voilà je rappelle que les produits
laitiers sont nos amis pour la
vie c'est rest important merci merci t à
merci d'avoir
été les sujets de conversation préférés
de 69 % des Français sont les potins
autes collègues ah ouais et ça c'est
vrai et je j'en profite je pense que
chacun va raconter un potin sur une
personne autour de la table euh donc je
vous laisse je vous laisse temps pour
raconter un petit potin et si vous ne le
faites pas attention je le ferai
moi-même donc je vous dis ça va être
chaud c'est
parti que ce soit à la cantine en posuse
devant le bureau ou encore à la machine
à café les salariés adorent discuter
entre eux tuas l'air en forme toi ce
matin je me trompe et une étude réalisée
auprès de plus de 900 personnes que
vient de publier l'Institut hiop permet
d'en savoir plus sur les discussions des
employés si la religion les relations
amoureuses encore le salaire figure
parmi les sujets tabou combien est-ce
que vous gagnez par mois je sais pas si
j'ai envie de le dire en fait 66 % des
salariés sondés affirme aimés se
plaindre de leur patron et de
l'entreprise mais 69 % d'entre eux soit
la majorité déclare que leur sujet de
conversation préféré sont les petits
potins entre
[Musique]
collègues qui a un potin moi quand même
[__] la vache j'ai pas besoin on le
chercher très loin il remonta hier soir
Raymond sortant l'émission tu vois ce
que je veux dire B très gentiment qu'on
vien une partous en
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
de sortez tous s'il vous plaît sortez
complè sortez s'il plaî c'est pas de
votre
âz tues toute
sa à sa des fa mais un à sa demandez
demande
demandez
pas mais tu sais qu'on la télé direct
les gens nous regardent mais tu un
malade on est prier ah merde ah ou es
comme une SAB c'était c'était un
monopolie non mais c'est vrai ils vont
rentrer tu vas la refaire ah d'accord ok
allez
rentrer rentrz rentz
oh lui chef de lui la allez mets-toi là
toi mets-toi là alors mets-toi je suis
pas d'accord je suis pas
d'accord je pas d'accord atttion on
rigole mais faut pas inventer non plus
on veut bien faire des B parce que tu
sais que les gens nous regarde là c'est
télévisé alors ton pote ton pote un vrai
hein un vrai vra moi je repars un vrai
travaille demain je repars pas de
souci vrai un vrai hier soir
mais j'allais préciser la ville au
moinsjà sa
mort ah oui je pleur [__] mais tu es
conain mais quoi sa femme regarde sa
femme regarde l'émission je savais
pas je savais pas ah oui ah oui j'en
sais rien mais c'est vrai qui qu' me
contrediseent les yeux dans les yeux les
yeux dans les yeux dis-moi ce que tu
veux dire les yeux dans les yeux dis dis
dis vérité bon les mecs les mecs ce que
je propose on fait le tour les PO et on
reviendra là-dessus on fait le tour on
fait tour are
po alors Jacques cardose nous a dit
qu'il travaillait et qu'il avait pas eu
le temps de regarder le film et je sais
de sources sûr que c'est faux puisque
cet après-midi je suis allée voir
Annabelle de viledieu qui est voyante
qu'on avait vu sur le plateau et il se
trouve qu'il était là juste avant moi
non oh là
là bien pas mal pas mal pas mal pas mal
mal je je je préfère je préfère celu-là
au
premier oui forcment et qu'est-ce alors
vous nous direz dans un instant ce
qu'elle vous la dit un petit peu B de
villeieu qui a un autre qui un potin qui
un potin oui je vais balancer une bombe
non euh on en a déjà eu là c'est bon
vas-y molo euh he on a encore toute
l'année à faire hein les mecs donnez pas
tout tout de suite hein on est non mais
c'est vrai ça va on est on est le 16
novembre on on a jusqu'en join je ne
dévoilerai pas je ne dévoilerai pas mes
sources le 13 avril 2017 lorsqu'il était
à France 2 ja C Mor comment
ça vous êtes
lour on voit bien que c'est
impossible alors i
lour qui en a levé la main tout àheure
moi j'ai levé la main j'ai non pas un po
mais un petit tac jaces cardose au nom
de tous mes collègues alors mten avant
qu'on continue tu sors de la
piscine
disillon encore 10 minutes ou quoi on
dirait la PE cou que tu as quand tu sors
de la piscine à l'école non mais et donc
ou bah j'ai des petites tentatives
capilair non c'est vrai que cardos
devient insupportable il travaille de
moins en moins et maintenant il exige
des moto taxis pour se déplacer sinon il
ne vient plus et ben écoute il viendra
plus des moto taxi je crois pas un
instant JAC un menteur menteur bon je
veux bien ah vous êtes prêts non
mais non mais je dois dire les chosesir
la vérité moi y a rien donc hier soir je
après l'émission effectivement j'ai vu
une conversation très animée entre
Jean-Michel mer et
[Applaudissements]
raymondz normalement je suis dis on va
revenir à toi est-ce que tu as un potin
oui alors ça s'est passé hier
soireionog
démaquillage c'était avantou après
arrêtezeprèsmissrèsémission d' les gens
vont croire là ah ils après l'émission
alors vas-y C après l'émission oui c'est
juste après l'émission et riment très
gentiment m'a entrepris m'a dit
qu'est-ce que tu fais ce soir je luii
dit bah j'ai déjà quelque chose et
cetera il me dit c'est dommage parce que
je suis convié à saintmort des fussé
n'importe quoi il est il le mec il donne
même des ves part le mot le mot VI sort
de sa bouche à une part tous il y aura
n'importe qu mais arrête tes conneries
les gens vont tu balances des villes
mais arrête t conneries bah des villes
oui oui bah
excuse-moi la ville la ville c'est pas
le
plusard parce que lui il s'arrête à la
ville non mais il va l'engueuler tu es
con quoi céit à la
varen non mais oh C su en V tu es con
non mais c'est il m'a dit on sera 16 don
[Applaudissements]
lui et je suis rentré dormir
hier dégoûz vous me
dégoûter mais pourquoi pourquoi on se RA
par qu'il faut amener un gâteau dans ces
cas je comprends pas en fait tu arrives
d'abord tu pass pass à la tuis une gette
des rois pour il y a une cagnotte c'est
pour offrir hein merci non mais c'est un
truc de fou et là franchement bravo Jean
maisout toute non pas bravo bravo de
quoi pour diffamation alors sur JIS
c'est un ami je veux pas
porter mais s'il faut je porterai plein
je précise que tout à l'heure dès que je
l'ai croisé je lui ai demandé si' é es
allé il m'a dit oui et je suis explosé
il m'a dit là il m'a dit il m'a dit je
suis crevé regarde il m'as dit ça ou
pas les gens j'applaudissent normal
comme si raconé que j'avais été cherché
du pain mais j que c'est jure que c'est
faux il un jure sur la tête de mes
enfants que c'est vrai ça y est ou
enfant les enfants faut les de ça quand
même non là je peux te parler de petites
minutes il devient fou en tant que
responsable bien sûr bien sûr euh écoute
on t'a relaissé ta
chance tu étais tu ÉIS parti longtemps
de cette émission ça fait un an que
voilà que tu étais parti là tu reviens
c'est bien gentil tu voilà tu retrouves
tes marques mais euh ne va pas trop vite
trop hein tu vois ou pas je pe la
refaire alors refaisla ah refaisla
c'était hier soir après
l'émission rmond m'a entrepris et M
convient une partous à sa FA avec toi
ser mais non arrête de dire des
conneries non mais il est fou il est
force dans SAV il est malade cel est-ce
que c'est vrai ou mais c'est pas vrai je
vais aller en partout après
l'émission je vais t'emmener toi en plus
tu me l'as proposé j'ai dit non mais non
mais non mais désamorce e désamorceer ce
bordel e désamorcemoi ce bordel parce
que les
gens on y croit ou on y croit alors ch
on va faire un cro demain demain à
20h45 faire ou parce que je sais qu'il m
pas qu il m jamaisci alexand merci al
merci vous n'y croyez pas jaces card non
j'y crois pas on vous donner la réponse
là tout de suite on va donner la réponse
la vraie rép moi crois vous y croyez V
il bossait très tôt ce matin il m'a dit
qu'il avait livré très tôt fou Daniel
moi j'y crois parce qu'il m'a dit qu'il
m'invité à une soirée hier
soire la la est-ce qu' t'a dit est-ce
qu'il t'a dit avec toi on sera
18 il m' dit on
sera lui c'est le 17 toi c'est le
18is non mais c'est tout et il y a un
pote à moi là qui me dit moi j'habite à
Succi j'aurais d arriver Guillaume
Guillaume calme-toi je connais ta meuf
calme-toi mon guigi calme-toi n'y croyez
pas donc je n'y crois pas parce que hier
j'ai assisté à cette conversation comme
je vous l'ai dit tout à l'heure
elle était très animée et évidemment
Jean-Michel Jean-Michel mer exagère
c'était pas 7 c'était 14 qui t' dit j'ai
peut-être mal entendu j'avoue peut-être
non mais vous êtes insupportable moi je
vais vous dire je vais vous dire ce que
j'en pense après moi j'y croya j'étais
le
19e tu veux pas te calmer toi ah là là
tu veux pas te calmer non ça t'intéresse
pas ou qu'est-ce qui dit le 20e alors
[Applaudissements]
qu'est- moi j'ai une chance j'ai une
chance comme je suis le chef ils me
mettent jamais dans leur galette je les
vois il discut en loge à côté mais moi
je vais vous dire j'ai eu Raymon tout à
l'heure et je vais lui demander ce qu'il
avait fait hier soir qu'est-ce que tuas
fait hier soir il m'a dit NON NON hier
soir je suis rentré j'ai dormi j'étais
explosé on était au téléphone en plus
c'est ce qu'il m'a dit hier
soir
par on dirait une garde à
vue s'il te plaît desamor si c'est pas
vrai parce que ça va lui faire des
problèmes me demandez pas de damorcer
Al vérité est-ce que c'est vrai ou
pas le r
tourne moi j'ai ça à faire je m'en fous
qu'est-ce qui s passé hier soire c'était
juste après
l'émission dans la loge des maquillage
rayon m'a entrepris m'a convié gentiment
non à boire un verre à boire un verre
voilà
bravo
bravo al Alexandre ouais tu sais que
c'est extraordinaire parce que j'ai fait
un film là-dessus ça pe peut garder un
secret Ctait sur la rumeur dans
l'entreprise tu vois voil is une fille
qui dit à ses copines alors tu es toute
seule elle en a marre d'être toute seule
elle dit non non non j'ai un mec c'est
mon patron c'était Pierre
Arditi ah ouais c'est ça tout mais j'ai
eu très peur quand tu m'as dis j'ai fait
un film sur ça je croyais que c'était
oui
surr av j'ai eu très peur je me suis dit
ouais je me suis dit ouais c'est c'est
voilà il m'a dit franchement là
honnêtement je veux pas être salop voilà
il m'a dit viens on boit un verre
c'était à Saint morort effectivement
voilà il m'a dit on sera une quinzaine
tout nu ça va être très
sympa alors
[Applaudissements]
justement le 27 juin 2023 mon fils
unique Naël a été tué par un policier
depuis 4 mois et demi il était en
détention provisoire après quatre
demandes de remise en liberté il est
finalement relâché une véritable
injustice comment la vie de mon fils
peut-elle avoir si peu de valeur quelle
message est envoyé un policier tue un
enfant arabou
noir devient millionnaire et sort de
prison retrouve sa famille
tranquillement pour les
fêtes moi je retrouverai plus jamais mon
fils par que ce que je voudrais lui dire
c'est que elle sous-entend que la police
est raciste elle sous-entend que la vie
d'un enfant noir ou d'un enfant arabe
selon la police aurait moins de valeur
c'est ce qu'elle c'est ce qu'elle dit
dans son dans son texte euh moi ça ça me
choque non euh bah si moi ça me choque
ça me choque parce que lesffit ne le
montre pas c'est ce qui s'est passé est
très malheureux je comprends sa douleur
mais je je je pardon mais il y a un
moment donné où bon qu'elle appelle à un
rassemblement qu'elle parle de de
quelque chose de choquant à propos de de
la cagnote mais il y a deux cognotes
deux cagnotes qui ont été lancées au
même moment ça qu'est-ce que tu veux la
population je dire oui voà mais la
justice est passée la justice est passée
les décisions sont passé euh bon Daniel
qui veut réagir B c'est très difficile
évidemment d'être contre ce ce message
parce qu'il est émouvant en revanche
c'est totalement irresponsable parce que
quand elle dit une phrase comme ça ça va
vous avez vu les émeutes ça va rallumer
le feu et et c'est c'est totalement
irresponsable de on va avoir à nouveau
des émeutes juste avec cette phrase là
et vous voyez bien que cette femme la
pauvre sa douleur elle est incom vra
discussion làdessus mais elle lit un
texte et elle est
instrumentalisé on évidment tout le
monde je suis désolé ça c'est pas un
sujet le vrai sujet c'est que était très
présente à la manifestation qui a
déclenché les TR la sœur d'Adama Traoré
qui qui a un combat voilà qui a un
combat contre la la police les Bur
policière donc je suis désolé il faut
pas se voiler les la face on on se sert
de la douleur de cette m pour à nouveau
rallumer le feu parce que c'est c'est le
combat certaines personnes excuse-moi il
faut le dire c'est le combat de
certaines personnes le chaos la
LFI va rentrer là-dedans peut-être j'ai
vu les seuls trucs que j'ai vu là-dessus
c'est c'est c'est des messages de lesfi
donc je suis désolé faut pas voilà
maintenant ça ne remet pas en cause la
douleur de cette mère mais on s'en sert
et c'est dégueulasse non déjà tu dis
qu'elle lit un texte moi je suis désolée
cette mère là elle vient de perdre son
enfant elle vient d'apprendre que
l'auteur de des faits a été relâché
forcément elle est elle elle est en
train de lire un texte je pense que
n'importe qui pourrait pas être spontané
dire les choses de lui-même je pense que
ça on peut pas lui reprocher ensuite moi
je comprends pas parce que quand je
relis la phrase qu'elle a dit un
policier tu tue un enfant arabe ou noir
oui c'est un fait ensuite il devient
millionnaire oui c'est un fait il sort
de prison oui fait j'ai pas fini j'ai
pas fini tu pe Laer terminer moi je ne
rrouverai plus jamais mon fils oui c'est
un fait en fait on peut pas lui
reprocher cette phrase c'est un fait
c'est la
réich ou alors tu as des illères où tu
fais semblon de pas voir quand il dit ça
ça c'est sousentendu évidemment comme
dit JAC que sil avait été blanc l'issue
n'aurait pas été la même entre les
liges P aurait pu dire quand la police
tu un enfant dit qu' un enfant noir ou
arabe c'est qu' sousentend sousentend
qu'est-ce que tu as pensé toi bah moi je
trouve que elle elle a un avocat un un
avocat qui est très très compétent il
aurait pu lui dire quand même lui
expliquer que c'était ce qui s'était
passé tout à fait légal et dans la juste
norme de ce qui se passe dans ce genre
d'affaire il a même été plus longtemps
plus il a été plus longtemps en prison
que si quelqu'un avait fait la même
chose il a fait plus de préventif que
quelqu'un d'autre parce que justement on
n pas on a voulu calmer les émeutiers et
calmer la population on l'envoyer un
message fort en le mettant derrière les
barreaux plus longtemps qu'il
naurait donc moment il est
aprs que j'ai lu ça sur les réseaux
genre le tueur de naë 4 mois de prison
il est tranquille non c'est 4 mois de
préventif il un procès ça 5S ou mais
c'est toi qui a desill Jean-Michel toi
qui a des parce que moi je suis
convaincu que si dans cette voiture
c'était un petit blondinet et ben on
aurait réfléchi jeis désolé on aurait
réfléchi à deux fois avant avant
d'appuyer sur la
G peux
pas
pré tu tombes pilepil dans le piège tu
tombes pilepil dans le piège qu'on vient
de décrire avec Daniel tout à l'heure
c'est-à-dire que le fait de de tenir ce
discours en partant du présupposé que
parce que ce serait un enfant noir ou
arabe la police aurait tiré ou aurait un
comportement qui serait différent par
rapport à un blond c'est insupportable
je
il les il y a pas un fait de racisme
dans la police qui soit prouvé aussi de
façon aussi évidente qu'X États-Unis il
y a eu des événements bien sûr je dis
pas que il y a pas des éléments qui
peuvent être raciste mais je veux dire
là tu
sousentendrais faut arrêter de toujours
stigmatiser mettre tout le monde dans le
même panier je suis pas en train de
dire si si je peux
dire
bonours mais mais je suis désolé je dis
que je pense simplement moi je pense que
dans la police en effet il y a une
branche qui est sûement minime mais qui
existe
ùés je termine juste il y a très peu de
cas non mais dis pas desbranch je te
laisse parler a pas Bran a des cas il y
a eu des faits
oui caricat je en dire en train de te
dire que c'est un milieu dans lequel en
effet
leô partout ai racistes chez les
Africains chez les Asiatiques qui sont
r particulier
Imposs mais ça a moins d'impact d'avoir
un boulanger raciste un policier raciste
il y a des moi j'ai grandi à ment la
jolie je connais bien la banlieu j'ai
fait toutes mes études là-bas et après
je suis parti à Paris j'ai vu moi mes
potes black et rebux qui étaient victime
de des lit de sale gueule pendant les
arrestations voilà donc après je parle
pas de cette affaire là et je dis pas
que ça
pport quel rapport aussi des blancs qui
sont tabassés parce qu'ils sont blancs
AE c'est
par tu peux pas tu ne peux pas le nier
mais c'est pas nié j'ai dit qu' de tous
les côtés les racistes on dire qu's sont
tous la police par que ça m'nerve laisse
finir la pense je pense que cette
femme-là lorsque il lui arrive ça voilà
elle perd son enfant qui a 17 ans après
évidemment je suis pas du tout d'accord
pour dire que c'était un petit ange loin
de là voilà bon il a fait ce qu'il a
fait bien sûr mais je comprends
effectivement sa douleur et je peux
comprendre qu'elle se pose cette
question voilà tout simplement on peut
se poser la question benah en fait ouais
c'est un dialogue de Sour en fait du
coup moi je suis quand même assez
choquée par ce que tu as dit Hugo malgré
tout parce que tu on a l'impression
queil y a une sorte de de de de système
de système un peu genre parallèle dans
la police un peu raciste avec des flics
qui se lèvent en gros pour aller tuer
des des noirs ou des
Arabes laiss finir caricature alors moi
je pense que oui il doit y avoir des
délites fciess absolument comme la
discrimination à l'AMB comme des avec
des des noms qui ont des consonances
plus ou moins on va dire arabe tout ça
oui qui trouvent pas d'emploi qui et ça
évidemment il faut le condamner et c'est
très grave mais en disant en dis Mo je
dis pas que les policiers se lèv le
matin entant raciste disant je all
but
sou quelques mètres plus loin juste
avant
il bien c'est ça oui non mais ce que je
veux dire c'est que tu sousentends que
une action d'un
policier il est dérapé parce que parce
qu'il a vu que ce serait un noir ou un
arabe et pas un blondinet c'est ce que
tu viens de
dire tu dis qu Mme était blond
question non mais on va pas refaire le
détail mais on sait que dans le déroulé
des faits il a eu plusieurs sommation
avant il aurait pu sarrêter donc dire
c'est pe moi je
disés SOP exct ce que tu as dit c'est
pas parce que on met en avant le fait
que potentiellement dans un métier qui
est très important dans une société et
où il a où il y a un port d'armes où il
y a une responsabilité de protection de
des civils c'est un métier qui est très
important ben c'est pas parce que on dit
qu'il y a un problème potentiel dans une
partie de cette population ça veut dire
que on est qu'on est qu'on dit
les c'est que quand on reçoit ici par
exemple des policiers ou des syndicats
policiers avec avec qui sont arabes qui
sont noir et ben tous me disent qu'ils
reçoivent des milliards d'insultes en
disant vous êtes des collaburs vous êtes
des Arabes de service donc ça veut bien
dire qu'il y a un problème ça veut dire
que eux ils disent exactement comme nous
comme Jean-Michel comme Jacques et comme
moi tu vois ils disent pas comme vous
ils disent que par exemple la police
n'est pas raciste et eux on les traite
de raciste parce qu'ils sont dans la
police donc tu vois bien qu'il y a un
problème en fait ça veut dire
qu'aujourd'hui
l' pas entendu s'il PL ce qui me gêne
dans ce qu'a dit Hugo c'est que on a
l'impression encore une fois d'un
racisme systémique il pas dit
j'ai encore rien dit donc je peux même
plus dire une phrase c'estàd que là il
il il a quand même dit que effectivement
on lui a tiré dessus parce qu'il était
euh noir ou arabe et s'il était blondiné
on lui aurait pas tiré dessus ça c'est
choquant là Hugo moi je m'insurge contre
ça qu'il y ait non mais qu'il bah
laissez-moi finir qu'il y ait dans la
police des dérapages on en parle souvent
ici bien entendu mais qu'il y ait une
organisation dans la police raciste
structurée
organzz une Bran vousvez une partie
d'une
populations bien
vousz
il y a pas une volonté dans la police
délibérée de tuer des noirs et des
Arabes si on dit ça c'est la révolution
en France impossible de dire ça c'est
tout ce que je voulais dire et je
termin
dit qu tu vis quand tu vis en banlieu tu
te rends bien compte que quand tu as un
look particulier quand tu as un style
particulier tout
CEE
second morts tous les jours si la police
il s'amusait à tuer sur les Arabes et
les Noirs toute la journ si il y aura
des morts tous les jours tu peux pas
dire que la police tue systématiquement
des noirs et des Arabes non mais jou pas
sur la sémantique des mot moi je sais
pas parler c'est juste tu as dit voilà
s'il était blond il serait parti moi je
lis autour de ça je me dis que tu penses
que la police tue quand il voit un noir
un Arab et pas quand c'est un blanc que
le système toujours la lumre sur le même
profil de personne et ça peut être
dangereux pour person rrouver dans un
instant les chér pour la suite de
l'émission il y a
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
palomb